a couple beautiful how'd y'all meet work
where do you work so who sexually
harassed
whom she harassed you you were the
boss hey this girl hey hey
heyy remember when you took a hard
question on the SATs and then all of a
sudden you're like no now I get it this
girl is beautiful
you yeah you're not ugly he's not an
ugly guy I'm not a good-look guy neither
are you that's it that's all I'm saying
how long have you been together 6 years
holy I don't see a ring no ring
what a idiot right I'm like you
my wife is much hotter than me and I
married that as soon as I could what are
you hesitating for you think you could
do better no and you open up your garage
one day as aing Maserati sitting in
there you're like oh know maybe there's
Ferraris there's no Ferraris bro got the
Maserati now you park that and youing
keep it in the house forever don't let
it go nowhere out of your sight